so we have different kinds of students
right uh we have introverted students
extroverted students and anything in
between
uh so i personally i i think i was a bit
of an introvert uh i found it difficult
to talk with anybody and everybody
so
my feeling was that if a professor back
in let's say 2004-2005
would have
certainly declared on the first day of
class that from today onwards we are
going to do active learning in this
course
i would have been
a little bit scared to put it mildly
uh the very the very fact that uh that i
had left home for the first time in my
life left the protective environments of
my school
and here i was all alone in a new
institute living in a hostel with my
mates
everything was new the only last last
semblance of familiarity was in the was
in the lecture room where the teacher
would come and very authoritatively
teach me
if that also fell away now i would be in
shutters that was my feeling
so i i told you that wouldn't be perhaps
better if for the sake of the
introverted students
selfishly speaking
that we perhaps introduce active
learning a little bit later
so so could you please recount for the
sake of i'm sure there will be other
introverted students will be listening
to this for their benefit what you told
me
sure
well the short answer to your question
is no
would not be better to delay
the most important thing to me as a
teacher
is not making all my students happy
the most important thing to me as a
teacher is learning
i want my students to learn the material
i'm teaching them it's
very important to me that they learn and
if i have a technique which is going to
promote learning
help them learn better
better prepare them for the examinations
that i'm going to be giving them
then i want to take full advantage of
that technique
and then i'll just bounce back to my
previous answer
it does
worry you if you're an introvert you're
initially probably going to resist
active learning
to some extent
but the research on active learning that
i quoted before was looking at the
students as a body introverts and
extroverts alike
and what it found is that the resistance
of both the introverts and the
extroverts the initial resistance of the
introverts may be a little bit greater
but
it's going to go away fairly quickly if
you're doing active learning correctly
and the students are going to learn more
the other thing is
you're i suspect exaggerating
how bad you would feel as an introvert
in finding yourselves being put into
this
where it would really be scary is if i'm
making you get up and talk in front of
the entire class
as even introverts
are not all that uncomfortable talking
to one or
at most two other people in a small
group for two minutes
that's not going to terrify you
no matter how strong an introvert you
are and i can tell you
you know i may not be acting like an
introvert now but trust me i am one
and i'm a very strong introvert in real
life
the reason i may not seem like one now
is because i'm a teacher
and what i found is that to be an
effective teacher i can't just
be like that i've got to get out there
in front of the students be connecting
with them transmitting information to
them
listening to them if they have questions
and so even though i am an introvert in
real life i have to at least pretend to
be an extrovert to be effective as a
teacher but if you're a student
and a strong introvert
it's not going to be as terrifying as
you're afraid of
to find yourself being asked to do
active learning the other thing i'll
briefly tell you about is i did a
research study
i don't know 20 years ago or so
in which i followed
a class in a chemical engineering class
through the curriculum
teaching them one
core course one required course
a semester for five consecutive
semesters
using all of the techniques that uh
most of the techniques i talk about in
the book including active learning
and i surveyed those students
the object of the research study was to
find out what will happen and if you use
these techniques repeatedly usually a
student might see active learning in one
class and then never see it again
my question was what will happen if they
keep seeing it with the benefits of
this technique shown by the research be
even greater if it's reinforced
and
i did that and i published quite a few
papers on it but one of the interesting
things is i surveyed the students in
every semester asking them how do you
feel about these little activities that
we're doing in class do you think
they're helping your learning
do you think they're hindering your
learning or
it doesn't make much difference i can
take them or leave them
and what i found is that in that first
semester that i taught
and i asked the students this question
right at the very beginning in the first
week of the course
i got a pretty good distribution but the
introverts because i also had a way of
determining who was introvert and who
was the extrovert the introverts were
more resistant more of them didn't like
these small groups than the extroverts
who thought oh this is great i love
talking to people and this gives me a
chance to do it
but what i found was that
later in the semester six weeks into the
semester i asked the same question
and
the resistance
from everybody dropped considerably
and by the end of the sequence of course
is after they've been doing this for a
couple of years the introverts actually
preferred
the group activities to just lecturing
to a greater extent than the extroverts
did and my theory about that is that the
introverts realized that if they had
been left
given the choice
many of them would have said no i don't
want to do that i want to work by myself
and so forth but after they had done it
for
three semesters or so
realized that
they were learning
in these activities in a way that they
had never before learned
and so they expressed an even stronger
preference for active learning than the
extroverts did that both groups really
liked it
but the introverts even more than the
extroverts
so uh
thank you for pointing that out in in
such a nice elaborate way uh so
regarding what i felt during my first
year and what happened later on i just
saved for the benefit of the students
who may be in a similar position as mine
so in my first year i was an introvert i
stayed that way
and i saw all around me students who
would bunch up in groups study together
so although there was no active learning
that was being actually done
during the classes but since we are in a
residential campus uh many of the
students actually chose some sort of
active learning in their own way
and
even though i stayed with my books much
longer than they did
they did better than me
so so i'm a professor of mechanical
engineering now uh and people think that
i have been and like an over-the-top
excellent student all the while it's not
true
okay i didn't do as well i as i should
have considered the considering the fact
that i was with my books all the time i
didn't do as well as i should have in my
first year but in my second year
i i just took a cue from some of my
friends and maybe opened up just a
little bit and i and i was very
privileged to have a very good set of
friends in my department so when i
when i roamed around
with them studied with them just a
little bit more than my first year
my academic performance simply increased
like
a huge it took a huge step forward so
there was not much difference in the
teaching style so to speak from first
year to second year but it was a change
in my attitude of me just trying to
consciously trying to open up a little
bit that really helped me out a lot so
i think if we can do it from our own
our own initiative as students if the
professor's input is there in terms of
the active
learning and this and the learning
center teaching it could be a huge huge
boost to
the whole spectrum of students so i
really believe that from an
anecdotal perspective also